Yeah, you just put this in here. Plug
in.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the first command in the Quran
when you open the Quran from the very
beginning from
the First command in the Quran,
do not associate
similars unto Allah knowingly. Similars
a nid in the Arabic language
is something that is similar to
something else. This is referred to as a
nid
and
its plural is dead.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's first
prohibition
do not associate
do not set up ascribe
similars unto Allah.
things, people,
places that you make similar to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The next
the first command of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
or
worship your lord.
These are the first things Allah teaches
us in the Quran.
The first command or
worship your Lord.
The first prohibition
do not worship other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala didn't just
say don't worship other than Allah.
He said in this verse do not ascribe
similars unto Allah.
Why? What does that mean?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us that there is nothing him.
He is completely unique and sublime.
He is unmatched.
Anything that you can conjure up in your
imagination, no matter how vivid,
even if that imagination
is guided by the descriptions of Allah
himself in the Quran, whatever you come
to imagine,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is not similar
to that. He says subhanahu wa ta'ala
and there is no equal to him subhanahu
wa ta'ala. He says
there is nothing unto him
yet he is all hearing allseeing.
He sees, he hears, but it's not the
seeing and hearing of anyone or anything
else.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us that the idoltors, those who
worship idols,
when they are put into the hellfire by
Allah,
they will be put there and placed there
with their idols.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells tells
the people of Isra who worship other
than Allah, you and your false gods
will be the fuel for the hellfire.
You won't just be in the hellfire.
You will be the fuel of the hellfire.
And so in
Allah tells us that there will be a
dialogue between these idoltors and
their gods, their false gods. Whatever
these false gods are, whether they be a
person Fidel, whether they be
stones, whether they be trees,
graves, whatever it is,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
their disposition towards their gods,
these things that they worship, they
crawled on their face for these gods,
they dedicated their lives to these
gods.
And so what will
their attitude and disposition be
towards these false deities in the
hellfire?
They will proclaim to these false
deities that we swear by Allah Almighty
that we were in clear
misguidance
when we would make you
speaking to their false gods when we
made you equal to Allah.
equal to Allah. What does that mean?
That means that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, he is the only one worthy of
worship.
He is the only one who is worshiped
rightfully in any way. And worship can
take place in many forms. There's
worship of the heart, worship of the
tongue,
things that we say, worship of the body
salah and hajj and jihad.
There's worship of a person's wealth and
his property and what he owns zakad
and so forth. And there's also worship
by abstaining from something. A person
does not drink alcohol out of worship to
of Allah. A person does not eat pork out
of worship of Allah. A person does not
take ribba out of worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And there can be an
almost endless combination of all of
these five places where
and can take place.
If a person directs any of this worship
to other than Allah,
they direct a worship of their heart to
other than Allah.
They fear other than Allah in a way that
is only
in a way that is only appropriate for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is
this person has made Allah has made this
thing
equal to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Not that this thing is equal or
comparable to Allah. No. But he has made
this thing or this person
equal in his worship of Allah and his
worship of this thing or person.
It's very important to understand
this point
and that is that when a person directs
his worship to other than Allah
then this person is essentially saying
Allah is worthy of worship and also this
thing or this person is worthy of
worship. So this person has now ascribed
to Allah attributed to Allah a nid
he has attributed to Allah a similar and
that is the first law that Allah has
governed humanity with and the genind
with and that is do not worship other
than Allah do not ascribe a similar unto
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
And so this is the first command of
Allah
in the Quran and this is the first
prohibition of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
starts out many of his commands
throughout the Quran when speaking about
the rights
and to
the rights because what is
oppression?
What is oppression? If we were to say
what is the definition of oppression in
the Quran of
the definition of oppression in the
Quran
it is placing something in other than
its rightful place. This is considered
to be oppression.
When a person takes the right of Allah
which is the worship of Allah and
directs it to someone or something else
this is oppression.
He has now taken this right of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and he has dealt oppressingly
oppressively
he's taken something that belongs to
Allah and given it to other than Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
likewise
what is the definition of alen
the definition of justice.
It is placing things in their rightful
place.
It is placing something in its rightful
place. This is called
in the Quran.
And so the greatest oppression
is that a person direct
his worship to other than Allah. And
this is why Allah describes
in the Quran and relates to us the
advice that gave to his son
that he said
he said my son
do not associate partners unto Allah
indeed a shik
This act is the greatest of oppression.
Does this mean that a person
oppresses Allah? Can the p can a human
being oppress Allah?
The answer is no.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says about
those who sin that indeed they did not
oppress us rather it is their own souls
that they oppressed.
Iban Abbas said Allah is too great to be
oppressed by his servants by his slaves
subhanahu wa ta'ala. But has the person
dealt with Allah in an oppressive
manner? Yes.
Subhanahu wa'tala.
And so when Allah discusses the rights,
the rights of the parents, the rights of
the wife or husband, the rights of the
neighbors, the rights of even animals,
when he speaks about the rights, he has
summed them up into 10
general rights.
in a verse which is in
it's verse number 36 from
and it is referred to by the end and the
as the verse of the division or the
distribution of rights.
And he begins
categorizing these rights with his right
over his servant. Subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
He commands
and worship Allah all of you and do not
associate
anything unto him. This this word
anything is very important. Why? Because
sh comes in many forms
and many of these forms are silent
killers. Silent killers. I want you to
imagine something with me. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
Have a
[Silence]
can be
mean.
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. The sin that Allah
has proclaimed twice in the Quran that
he will never forgive.
A person can be forgiven by Allah for
atrocities.
He can be forgiven by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala for the most heinous and
atrocious
of histories.
However, what he will not forgive and
never forgive is a ship
in any of its forms.
And so this is a silent killer. I want
you to imagine with me that you are
resurrected in front of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
The ground is split and you are brought
forth. You come out, you crawl out of
your grave and there are the two angels
there waiting for you.
some scholars mentioned four angels.
Some mentioned the ones that were
writing your deeds throughout the dunya
that they will be there to direct you to
the place of judgment in front of Allah.
And as you are on your way to meet
the creator of all that exists,
the infinite,
the one who has no beginning and no end.
Everything you could possibly desire is
found sub in his hand. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And everything that you could ever fear
is also at his disposal.
And you come before Allah
and it turns out that
there are actions, there are statements,
there are beliefs that you spent your
days and nights in the dunya.
These things were acts of shik.
What kind of problem is this?
Is there any problem that can be
imagined that is more horrifying than
this? No takebacks. Can't go back.
There's no, "Oh, I didn't know. I was
unaware. You live. I gave you life for
20 years, 30 years. I gave you a mind so
powerful, an intellect so powerful, you
could imagine what is unimaginable.
you could imagine
things that can't even exist.
I gave you an intellect so powerful
that you were able to comprehend my
words that I sent to the prophets and
messengers. I gave you free will. I gave
you health. I gave you comfort.
What did you spend it doing? You didn't
have time.
You didn't know.
Seriously, this idea is a plague that we
have. Many of us feel that we can get
off on a technicality.
The technicality of I didn't know.
I misunderstood.
I didn't mean
right. That technicality,
the technicality of I'm not a scholar.
You were not commanded to be a scholar.
You could literally learn what Allah has
commanded you you and what he has
demanded of you in
if you spent a half an hour each night
studying the books
of the scholars of Islam which speak on
various subjects. You could learn the
things that are prohibited, the things
that are demanded, the things that are
expected of you.
But a person lives 30, 40, 50, 60, 70
years and you didn't know, what were you
spending your time doing?
And so we have this idea that, well, if
I didn't know, I I'm automatically
forgiven.
That may apply to some things, but could
you imagine if a person goes barreling
down the road at 150 m an hour, police
stops him? What are you doing? Oh, I
didn't know that I couldn't speed. I had
no idea.
The IRS shows up. Oh, I didn't know I
had to pay taxes. I didn't know. Would
that be acceptable? Who would accept
such a pathetic
such a pathetic excuse?
A lack of knowledge is only acceptable
when a person exhausts
his opportunities. He did his best.
But especially in our time, the the the
the time of internet that moves at
breakneck speed, entire libraries
of hundreds and thousands of years of
scholars works at the tip of your
fingers and you didn't know.
And so this is the most important thing
we can learn and the greatest right of
Allah which is
worship Allah and do not associate
anything anyone unto Allah in your
worship. We will end with that for
this afternoon. Inshallah we ask
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to teach us.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
taught Abu Bakr a dua specifically about
this specifically about because he said
that is so silent in my umah it's like
the footsteps of ants and Abu Bakr said
then what can we do what can we say he
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
in one of the earlier opening verses of
he says subhanahu waala which translates
to indeed
it is only
the one who
believes in Allah and the last day
and establish establishes prayer
and gives zaka
and does not fear and revere other than
Allah.
It is only this type of person who truly
builds the houses of Allah.
Builds the houses of Allah. Many people
have heard this verse before. They
misunderstand this verse.
What they understand this verse to mean
is building its physical walls.
That it's only permissible for the most
righteous of men to build the walls, the
physical walls of the masid and the
house of Allah. And that's not what is
intended by the verse.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
affirmed
the building of the Kaa which happened
before our prophet Sam
was even a messenger
more than a decade before he was a
messengerat.
It is the mushikim,
the idoltors, the pagans, the
polytheists
from amongst
who rebuilt the Kaa, the house of Allah.
And when the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
conquered Mecca and it became a home for
Islam
and it was
reverted back to the pure house of Allah
and scrubbed clean of the filth of
idolatry. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
not command the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam to rebuild it to tear it
down because it's only those who believe
in Allah in the last day that can build
the houses of Allah what's meant here by
building the houses of Allah
is
establishing the houses of Allah
building it with worship shipped
building the houses of Allah by
worshiping Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
these houses
in the house of Allah who are those who
are the rightful builders of the worship
of Allah on the earth it is those who
believe in Allah in the last day
establish prayer they don't just make
salah
they don't pray.
They establish prayer.
Which means when they stand to make
salad, they fulfill it and give it their
all each and every time.
And this only comes by way of
determination,
only comes by way of practice, only
comes by way of learning and
implementing
the sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasam.
You won't find that Allah commands in
the Quran, pray everyone pray. That's
not good enough. It is establish prayer.
Establish prayer
which means to fulfill the prayers
conditions
and pillars and obligations and sunnah.
Pray as the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
prayed and pray with your hearts
not just with your body.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describes the type of men that establish
the houses of Allah with their worship.
They are those who believe in Allah in
the last day. They establish prayer.
They give zak and they do not fear with
reverence other than Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. We're not speaking about fear of
snakes or fear of death or fear. These
are natural fears. We're speaking about
fear with reverence. Fear with with
worship out of worship of other than
Allah. Pede your worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. These men don't
have that. They don't have that kind of
fear.
They
worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. They
stand for the truth and justice and they
stand for the sunnah of Muhammad.
Wasam in spite of everyone and
everything around them.
They are not
shamed into cowardice.
They are not shamed and made weak by
the blame of those who antagonize them.
Rather, their enemies only make them
bolder.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala not
only describes the type of people
that the mass the houses of Allah were
built for but he describes
what kind of environment the masid is
supposed to be. The masid, the house of
Allah, a companion,
may Allah be pleased with all of them,
once came to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
and he asked him, "Oh messenger of
Allah, what place on the earth is
closest to Allah?"
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
He wasn't speaking about a specific
place. He was asking about a type of
place.
What types of place on the earth are
closest to Allah?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
Allah
I have to ask.
I know in our time this is unbelievable
that a person who doesn't know something
would say I don't know I have to look
into it because now we live in the time
of I know everything and I have an
answer for everything here the messenger
of Allah
says I do not know I have to ask ji
and he asked ji and ji said, "Aham,
I have to ask."
And so, Jirel returned to the prophet
Sam. Wasam and told him the places on
earth closest to Allah.
The closest places on the earth to Allah
are the massid
is the masid
and the furthest place on the earth from
Allah
is the marketplace.
The marketplace is supposed to be the
exact opposite of the masid or rather we
could reverse that. The masid is
supposed to be the stark contrast to
everything the marketplace is. When you
look at the marketplace, why is that the
worst place? It's the worst place
because that is the place that brings
out the worst in people.
And the masid is the place that is
supposed to bring out the best in
people.
The marketplace
is what brings out of people greed,
enmity, viciousness,
Mcavelian attitude.
The marketplace is where people lie and
cheat one another and try to get over on
one another. Where men and women mix
together freely.
Where indecency is rampant.
Where people go and forget about the
hereafter because of their excitement
over the dunya. That is the description
of the marketplace.
It's a place that's loud, chaotic.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
would tell the companions in the masjid.
He would say to them, "Beware of
bringing the chaos of the market into
the masid."
The masid is supposed to be the stark
opposite of what the marketplace is.
that when a person comes to the masjid,
it brings out the best in them. It
brings out their hope, their reason,
their remembrance of Allah. It brings
out their truthfulness, their courage,
their honor. It is a place where people
come to be purified by Allah. And Allah
says as much
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala described
the masid as
that it is a place that has in it men
who desire with every fiber of their
being that they be chosen by Allah to be
purified.
Purified from their foolishness.
Purified from their cowardice. Purified
from their shortsightedness
and perversion.
Purified. And Allah tells us about the
men in the masid. He says indeed Allah
does love those who seek to be purified
and those who are in constant constant
repentance to Allah.
They want to be purified inward and out.
They want to be changed
and metamorphized by Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala in the masjid.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
commanded throughout his days in Medina
teaching the companions
how to make the masid as different and
separate from the marketplace.
He sallallam
prohibited buying or selling or
advertising in the masid. And he said
inah
that if any of you sees someone buying
or selling in the masid, then say to
him, "May Allah make this transaction of
yours fail." Because the masid was not
built for this. Listen to those words.
The masid was not built for this. Look,
no one of us here is getting paid to
come in here today. We are here gathered
because we believe that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has commanded us to be here.
It's a place that gathers people of all
ages, people of all walks of life. The
professionals, the intellectuals
sit right next to those who are not so.
And the rich and the poor come together
and sit on the same ground and pray
shouldertosh shoulder. What an
opportunity
for the savvy salesman. What an
opportunity this this presents for a
person who is wishing to exploit the
house of Allah to line his own pockets.
And so the prophet sallallah.aihi
wasallam taught the companions how to
protect the masid from that. The masjid
is not made and built for people to
exploit
by buying and selling.
It is not built for people to exploit
for their personal or worldly agendas.
The masid is the place where people come
in order to be purified and repent to
Allah. And Allah loves those who are in
constant repentance. And Allah loves
those who seek purification.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam even
prohibited
announcing lost items in the masid.
He prohibited in Muslim that a person
who's lost an item come to the masid and
announce it to the people in the masid
looking for it. not permissible. The
prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,
he said,
"Whoever you find in the masjid
announcing his lost items, then say to
him, may Allah not return to you your
lost item." The masid was not built for
this.
Look at how the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam taught the companions to
protect the house of Allah. It's not for
buying and selling. It's not for your
political agenda. It is not for you to
exploit. It's not for your Instagram
clicks and followers. The masid is the
house of Allah where people come to try
to get to paradise, to try to be good in
a bad world, to try to find light in the
darkness, to try to revive their hope in
a hopeless world. That is what the masid
is for. So do not bring the marketplace
into the masid.
And he would command the companions
again as we mentioned
as well.
Stay away and beware from bringing the
chaos and the sounds of the marketplace
into the masjid. And that is why the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
has mentioned that one of the signs of
the hour.
One of the signs that the is about to
emerge, one of the signs that Allah is
preparing the earth to be folded up and
ended is that the marketplaces will
become all connected. No matter where
you go, you can't escape it. Even in the
masid, you can't escape the marketplace.
I'm sitting between and many people
will sit between and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said that if you
repeat after the mu what he says and
then you make the dua after. If you
repeat what the muadin says and then
make dua, Allah will answer your dua. I
remember one of the students
one of the students of knowledge, he
had related that he had a lot of
problems. He had a lot of issues that
were wearing him down and were affecting
his personal life and his studies. We're
speaking about students of knowledge,
people that seek knowledge of the Quran
and Sunnah. And he said, "So I decided
to not pass up a single time between the
adan and the without making fervent dua
that Allah make things better for me."
He said, "I did this only for a short
time, a month or two, and I was given so
much more than what I asked for to the
point that I was ashamed of myself in
front of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala."
Meaning Allah gave me so much more than
I could have ever asked just by doing
this small thing. the few minutes that I
was, I felt that I didn't have a right
to all these things Allah was giving me.
We'd rather jump on Amazon real quick
and look to buy some things. This is
impermissible. This is haram in the
masid. This is not what the masid is
for. The masid has not been built for
these things. And part of the exaltation
of Allah is exalting the masid, the
house of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has said,
he says,
He says regarding the Kaa and the masid
by extension
and those who exalt the houses of Allah,
they do so only to their betterment with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It is of the
best and most noble of things that a
person can do is to
exalt the masid, the house of Allah.
When I come into the masid, I am clean.
I don't have any bad smells with me. I
don't bring dangerous weapons into the
masid that are could potentially harm
the people that have come to seek peace.
I do not bring things into the masid
that will harm people. I lower my voice.
When I come into the masid, I feel like
I am in a place no other. That is
where we start on our path to redemption
as a people. We start with the masid.
It's the It's the heart inside
of the body for any community, the
masid. All of the blood goes back to the
heart. It's regenerated, reoxygenated,
and is sent back out to the rest of the
body. That is what the masjid is for.
And it is the best of men and women who
are those who are at their best in the
masid. We ask Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that he teach us true reverence of the
masid that he subhanahua
make our masid pure and purifying for
[Arabic recitation]
Allah has encouraged that we recite
on the day of J. The day when attending
the masid is an obligation upon those
who fit the criteria and Allah first
tells us about some young men who found
refuge in a cave and were purified by
Allah and he subhanahu wa ta'ala has
given us a cave similar to that. That is
what the masjid is. The masid is our
cave that we retreat to in order to be
spared and saved from the dunya. We ask
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala that he
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
with his grace and mercy and forgiveness
that he grant us the enlightenment and
the knowledge necessary to recognize the
truth when we hear it to the that he
grant us the courage to adhere to that
truth and the audacity to remain upon
and for that truth. that he grant us the
honor of dying for and upon that truth
and the nobility of being resurrected
with his people.
All
[Silence]
becoming
Allah
[Silence]
asleep.
Allah
[Silence]
Allahhammed.
He was here. Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
But
allah
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder.
Stand shouldertosh shoulder, foot to
foot. Be as straight and coherent in
your rose as possible throughout the
prayer. Please turn your phones off.
Turn off any distractions.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Foreign
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
I am
[Silence]
Allah.
So me Allah
[Silence]
Allahel.
Allahbel.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
So now we're Yeah.
[Silence]
Allah
say Allah
Allahbel
Allahel.
Allahbel.
I don't know.
[Silence]
number.
Allah
salam.
How's everything?
[Silence]
Looks I have to go down to italam.
So I'm just going to remind you a few
programs that we have inshallah going on
at the masjid and encourage you to take
advantage of it. we inshallah have
many programs.
The first one I'm going to tell you
about is on every Saturday we have two
classes for Quran. They're one for
the brothers and one for the sisters and
they run simultaneously.
It's from 11:00 a.m. I'm sorry from 11
to 1:00 p.m. So make sure you take
advantage of that and there is no cost
to this.
Another program we have is the MCCT
youth soccer program, which is a club
that's run on Wednesdays and Fridays.
And it's between 2:45 on I'm sorry, I'm
sorry. Take that back. Saturdays between
1:30 and 2:30 and on Saturday again at
2:45 to 4. So the soccer program runs on
Saturday. Now, we have also a a
basketball program, and that's the
program that runs on Wednesdays and
Fridays, and it's between 4:15 and 6:15.
So, make sure you take advantage of any
of these programs. If you yourself or
you have a youth that can lift from
that, please come and join and be at the
mid as you heard from the that this is
the place that you wanted to be
[Arabic recitation]
Also, there is two upcoming events. One
is going to happen on these on Saturday
the third Saturday of this month.
Inshallah our im will be doing a
workshop for zaka. So if you have any
question about zaka, how to you know to
calculate your zaka, how to do your
obligations, you have different
scenarios that you want to know about,
please come and join us. It's an aer
time third Saturday of this month
inshallah. So make sure you attend. And
one last event that's going to happen
Saturday, September 6 and this is
for boys. So all boys inshallah, if
you're interested, make sure that you
hook up with brother Hassan and ask
about this. It's on September 6
inshallah. This is going to be 1 hour
before. So it's but make sure that you
if you have any questions that you work
with us. please do donate donate
generously. We are having a lot of
expenses. So help us to help you
[Arabic recitation]